sie alle müssen ausziehen 40 Menschen
hier bekamen schon in Brief mit der
Ankündigung zur Kündigung der Grund sie
sollen Platz machen für ukrainische
geflüchtete für die Mieter ein Schock
ich hab ehrlich Angst sind mein Zukunft
wo muss ich umziehen und und wie und wie
kann ich meine Miete zahlen wenn 700 800
€, das ist nicht zahlbar für mich von
außen ansehnlich innen total veraltet
die Wohnungen aus den 50er Jahren
gehören der städtischen
Wohnungsbaugesellschaft hier wohnen
Menschen mit wenig Geld die meisten
finanziell unterstützt von der Stadt
doch die will die Arbeiter Siedlung
jetzt als Flüchtlingsheim nutzen das kam
für alle in der wölblinstraße
überraschend auch für Sami muldner
Erlebte mit seiner Mutter in einer
Zweizimmerwohnung für 400 Euro und
schätzt vor allem den Zusammenhalt unter
den Nachbarn
wir wissen nicht was am Ende passiert
wie es am Ende aussieht aber das wird
die Zeit eigentlich ich glaube keiner
hier weg Lörrach liegt nahe der
Schweizer Grenze die Mieten sind hoch
eine Wohnung von Privatanbietern für die
meisten Menschen hier unbezahlbar
Wohnungsbaugesellschaft und
stadtversprechen finanzielle
Unterstützung und Hilfe beim Umzug in
eine neue Wohnung der Wohnbau Lörrach
keinem soll er es schlechter gehen doch
in den sozialen Medien bricht ein
Shitstorm aus
Beleidigungen Drohungen und Hetze gegen
geflüchtete den Oberbürgermeister und
die Wohnungsbaugesellschaft
und die Boulevardpresse wütet mit
wir haben hunderte von Hassmails
tausende von Anrufen inzwischen erste
Brief die Post braucht ein zweiter
Teilen
bekommen eines Inhalts schwer erträglich
die Pläne der Wohnbau Lörrach sind so
schnell zum Politikum in ganz
Deutschland geworden der parteilose
Oberbürgermeister und der
Geschäftsführer der
Wohnungsbaugesellschaft für viele die
Sündenböcke währenddessen sind die
meisten Mieter genervt von der
bundesweiten Aufregung um ihre Wohnungen
denn manch eine hier kann mit den Plänen
der Wohnungsbaugesellschaft sogar sehr
gut leben
ich verstehe nicht warum man daraus eine
große Sache macht weil die Wohnbau gibt
uns ja was besseres die sagen ja nicht
okay jetzt seit der auf der Straße und
die sagt man jetzt Ukraine werden hier
wohnen im Gegenteil ich meine anders
die neue Wohnung bekommen werden solche
Stimmen passen jedoch nicht in die
politische Agenda derer die die Bewohner
für ihre Propaganda instrumentalisieren
und die Sorgen der Menschen zu Hetze
gegen die Migrationspolitik missbrauchen
die AFD hat jetzt sogar Strafanzeige
wegen Nötigung gegen die Wohnbau Lörrach
gestellt
möchte das nicht unterstützen
100%ig ich bin selber halber ausländer
können wir sagen könnte man so sagen und
deshalb nee ich halte mich dazu um
Lörracher Rathaus sieht man der Klage
von der AFD gelassen entgegen aufklären
und um Vertrauen werden sei jetzt das
Ziel von Stadt und
Wohnungsbaugesellschaft den eines ist
unbestritten Lörrach braucht mehr Platz
um geflüchtete unterbringen zu können
die Wohnungen in marodenhäusern mit
veralteten zimmeröl Öfen sind
heruntergekommen die Stadt hatte
eigentlich schon ihren Abriss geplant
nach einer Renovierung sollen sie jetzt
noch für eine Übergangszeit als
Unterkunft für ukrainische geflüchtete
dienen kein neuer Vorgang erklärt der
Oberbürgermeister Fragezeichen
zufrieden ist ja die Politik nicht
reklamiert die Stadtgesellschaft und für
den
mieterinnen-situation Mieter aus alten
Gebäuden in neue Wohnungen umsiedeln das
machen sie hier schon lange bisher ganz
ohne Skandal ohne Probleme für die
Mieter und der Bürgermeister ergänzt
dass man in Lörrach um das wohl alle
sozial schwacher Menschen bemüht sei und
Spiele nicht Miete gegen geflüchtete aus
die Welle der Empörung schlägt trotzdem
hoch wir halten diesen professionell aus
auch wenn es für uns eine Lastwagen die
Mitarbeiter die Telefon annehmen wo die
E-Mails einprassen
die auch von
verschiedenen Kanälen und Gruppierung
wirklich traktiert werden
auf Klarheit von Stadt und
Wohnungsbaugesellschaft und er hofft auf
neue bezahlbare Wohnungen für sich seine
Mutter
und alle 40 Bewohner der wölblinstraße
in Lörrach